[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits this week at the
round table of dim lighting it is me
rhett and me link and we're going to be
talking to one another but we're going
to be talking to you at the same time
answering your questions
it's a Q and an A we got your Q's we
give the A's
we got yous we have days we got the Q so
we can get the eggs and if we gave the
A's without the Q's it would be
confusing or confusing and I'm gonna
give us an A preemptively forever days
because we don't get grades anymore you
know ma yeah the kids get the kids that
we have I don't know what grades are you
know they get grades oh yeah they get
great oh you know they do I mean another
kind of they do some home schooling they
do some charter schooling but they're
getting great it's really freeform and
then when my wife was out of town I was
grading Shepherds work and I was and I
was like are you capable of that oh yeah
I had a red pen well it takes more than
that you got to know what if the answers
are right well it was like second grade
math exactly so I got I knew all the
last time you did second grade math it's
second grade but I was checking well
actually you do second grade math like
all the time it's like the math that you
still need I busted out a calculator
today to like do some subtraction some
some fraction and so I'm doing I'm
checking and I'm putting check next text
next to the ones that are right in X's
next to the ones that are wrong yeah and
then you're like a drill sergeant and
then I like gave him a grade and then I
did a smiley face and I was like great
job Shepherd I just found myself
becoming a teacher
and wishing that maybe I'd have done
that are you serious it was cool it was
just a nice sensation but you didn't
literally wish that you would have
become a teacher no you know in that
moment I was like a teacher right I
don't know have any idea never smart
that's one of the best jobs in the world
you get to invest into the youth of
tomorrow it's it's one of the most
important jobs honor shield for the
record but as children are the future
it's a thankless job yeah but I mean I
think you stay young it's like being a
mom I think you said a young people's
kids it's like my dad but yeah but you
don't you don't to put him to bed male
or female to be a tea
you don't have to put a hillock thanks
for clarifying well I said mom I didn't
want to just mmm I know I'm not saying
well you know what I want to be I wanted
to be a professor I think is what I want
it to be because when you're a teacher
like of school-age kids and you have to
like worry about their development and
stuff you know I don't have time for
that right professor is just like it's
about you I wear an ascot and I think
all of you laugh and I do research and
in the summers I go to the sabbatical
Antigua for research like well they they
go on sabbaticals which is like extended
vacation your dad his dad's a professor
of law of college law well that's not
the university like real estate law or
something well college is typically what
they call undergraduate law schools
graduate school so he's just a law
professors were they call it in the
industry
law professor teacher of law what was my
point that he take sabbatical has he
ever taken us about it no daddy Mack
ain't got time for sabbaticals man what
you said was revealing when I really
honed in and what you actually wanted
when you were Grady Shepards paper the
first thing you said when you talked
about being a college professor was make
them laugh to say some jokes oh yeah I
just want a captive audience might that
wants to suck up to you for good grace
yeah you get all the laughs my dad is a
comedian he's a stand-up comedian he
stands up in front of a class and makes
him laugh now they also about real
estate law that's a challenge he's not
great he's doing I think he does wills
and trusts at this point know some other
things I mean he's he'd like he writes a
book to do you know they're just like a
book and I've heard North Carolina law
and he like writes the book and like
updates it every year
daddy Mac's guide to wills and trips and
he's like well it trusts sometimes I
talked to him and I'm like what are you
doing he's like I'm uh I'm updating the
book I'm updating the book again he
takes pride because of the years look
Shane up shady oh yeah cuz the laws
change and you gotta you gotta
anticipate and incorporate laws well you
could have been a professor so yeah I
could use those multiple syllable words
right back to back like that that's what
they do
but really what happens is whenever he
updates his book he gets paid again
well you didn't have to say that he gets
paid yeah cuz they they got to buy the
new one right it's like so and although
business of law yeah that's why I update
you know that's why I update my my look
every once in a while every ten years or
so get paid again so people kit will
keep watching this or listening yeah
that's why you cut your hair yeah so cuz
people were dropping off he'll come back
it's like new and him same product new
and improved packaging yeah your your
glasses that subtly changed over the
years I mean that's that's one of manage
you've got over me I don't have I wear
that can change subtly over time people
don't know that you've been through 74
pairs of glasses and if you watch a lot
of our videos closely you'll see you can
see the very subtle changes but well
honestly knee for black bears honestly I
know I've been 174 five five okay I have
styles of glass it allows a little bit
off a little over 10 years yeah well you
kind of ruin my point but 74 would have
been would have made it seem you were
making a point I think your point was
will you give us an A I'm tasting the
blood okay we're gonna answer some
questions think you're not concerned
about that
see sometimes I toss out something like
I'm tasting the blood and then you'd
ignore it totally but it was my segue
and it's telling you about something
okay you take something what do you mean
that's it that's how your tongue I bit
my tongue when I was eating that that
bowler rice thing beforehand yeah and I
I it's still bleeding a little yeah I
you know what hey I've kind of gotten to
the to this yeah I've gotten to a point
in our friendship where I don't want you
to tell me when you bite your tongue
because it happens more often than you
change your glasses it annoys me that
you never bite your tongue do you even
have one your teeth are so recessed but
you have small little tea don't ain't no
ice is about your teeth I'm incredibly
careful no no are you constantly careful
not about your tongue yeah I've never
done it I'm awesome careful it's an
Anatomy thing no you know what happened
to me I was born tall
I grew up tall and lots of people think
that tall people are clumsy but I have
just like cat-like I guess yes and like
going through doors I'm really caught
self-conscious about hitting my head or
stepping on people you would think older
tall guy he's a giant he steps on people
my five-foot-three wife steps on my feet
way more than I step on her feet I don't
think I've
ever stepped on anybody's feet they're
way down there and you still don't step
on and I don't bite my tongue very
office I think your point is constantly
thinking about not injuring myself I
think that's my secret but what I what I
take you to mean is that you don't
constantly tell me about how tall you
are so I shouldn't constantly tell you
that I'm biting my tongue cuz it happens
every day yeah yeah happens all the time
it's like it's like you saying you Lee
you remember I'm tall right yeah yeah so
you know I'm tasting the blood you can
just you know chances are I'm biting my
tongue yeah constantly but ironically
metaphorically I will own the fact that
I should bite my tongue more often
Missha meaning not say something that
I'm about to say yeah yeah you should do
that kind of button but on this show we
say whatever we want that's why we do
this show but you know also speaking of
shows that we do at almost forgot it is
official we can announce it right now
because we did also announce it on good
mythical morning today yes buddy system
season 2 on YouTube rare harmonic that
was like flat and I held up four red
links buddy system on YouTube bread our
scripted show that we absolutely love
making there's more I just said love
making yeah that's I didn't want you to
give away the subject matter this season
Oh season two is all about love man not
really we love making it it's longer so
there's more love to be made yeah
half-hour episodes which really just
means 22 minutes in like television
terms but it's not on television so it's
somewhere around that length 50% more
buddy system in season two where we're
in the process of writing it and super
super excited about it really hoping
that those of you who don't have youtube
bread yet will consider getting it
because more and more stuff is coming to
the platform but mostly we just want you
to watch our show because we have a
blast making it the creative that's
coming together right now is so so
strange and weird it's so
strain and what I hope is a wonderful
way I think you know I it's it's not
good until he gets strange I think we're
like pushing it and we're we're we're
we're in a room with some writers and
we're like collaborating
yeah we're collaborating more I'm season
one week which is fun it was not just
the two of us just the two of us eating
and now with these episodes being longer
and also kind of having set the template
in season season when we wrote it
ourselves we're like this is how we want
to do a world you know yeah and so now
that you've done that you kind of have
some tracks to run on you could bring in
some experienced and qualified writers
to collaborate with so we're getting not
just our weird ideas their weird ideas
we got lots of weird ideas and there's
lots of things many moments that are
happening everyday in the writers room
where I'm like should we do this and
which means yes and then whenever we ask
that questions like is this too crazy
you know that you know a sweet spot the
question I'm asking is like is it weird
enough yet and then we keep pushing we
just gotta push just gotta keep pushing
we made a post on the Facebook and we
asked you to ask us questions in a near
biskits format which that's not exactly
what we asked and what I said didn't
mean anything
yeah ask us questions in a near biskits
format no I don't I don't know it's like
words coming out of my mouth you just we
just ask you to ask us questions and now
we're gonna go through some of them
we're gonna answer him on the format
call to your biscuits yeah
Brandon falling falling he's falling
okay I'm I almost did a voice but I'm
not going to cuz I don't know what his
voice sounds like and I don't want to
insult him with a voice yeah so I'll
just give him my voice this is just my
voice Brandon not yours I'm reading your
answer in my voice so you should do it
you're crushed you should do an
impression of just a any voice okay so
I'm a landscaper and absolutely love
what you do with sprays as what I do you
just totally made the question about us
no that's what I was concentrating on
I'm a landscaper and absolutely love
what I do
okay that's good points I gotta go back
to my voice make no presumptions about
what he did whether you read it right if
I'm gonna do a voice
I was thinking too much about my voice
okay so I'm Alam hates you now I'm a
landscaper and I absolutely love what I
do
with spring here it's a good time to ask
my question what are your yards look
like lbs I don't know lbs stands for
pounds how many pounds are your yards
do you enjoy mowing your grass and or
any yard work good question presents a
big big question we get it all the time
now I think we may have said this before
and it's gonna sound a little I mean
listen I didn't know when you moved to
Los Angeles that 98% of the people who
live here regardless of socio-economic
study it's Jan I'm a professor will you
somebody cuts your yard somebody does
your landscaping and the first time I
went below the yeah the that's the
company that does it for me
the that's what it's called the first
house that we ran in here after the the
short-term apartment that we were in the
the guy was like and it comes with a
gardener and I was like oh it must be
nice and it wasn't it wasn't nice I just
learned that every house most houses
there's a gardener and when it is
concluded with the rent and just to do
to cut the grass because your yard does
not come with a garden don't have an out
of no garden in it so someone who mows
it then blows it in any and if you're in
North Carolina and you got somebody who
you paid them on your grass you're just
highfalutin yeah well I mean it means
you're just kind of a rich or a rich
softie rich softie you know what I mean
but here it just means you're just an
Angeleno you're just a Los Angeles
person so I got to say that I haven't
cut grass in a very long time and I
don't know what it's doing to me but
what if the yard look like I actually
have very very little grass I have a
little strip of grass that I would say
is because my house is on a hill your
gardeners making out like a bandit no
we've got a little strip of grass no but
he's he's dealing with vines and plants
in a slope that has some sort of ground
cover on it there's quite a lot going on
but
gret and then there's one part that's
almost caught all concrete where we got
the basketball goal but then there's
that like six feet by 25 feet rectangle
of grass yeah which I actually recently
actually recently talked to my gardener
about making into just artificial turf
that's a good idea because he but then
the dog poop
you got it fits on top but you have to
clean it up but that's on top if it's
real grass that will biodegrade you
don't you just let your dog crap just
descend into the earth well I don't like
a lost soul Jade does it on like crushed
granite well look at you mister crushed
granite
[Applause]
yeah I'm a highfalutin softie man I got
crushed granite oh no she has like a
spot that she poops on look at ya you
know that strip of crushed granite I got
there on the side of the house it's just
like hard dirt in the back on the side
but within the gate within the gate
within the gate I don't let the dog out
of the gate well I do but then she
attacks like poodles that are walking by
I you know what I need I don't need a
gardener
I need a concrete cleaner because she
poops on that too no I'm just saying my
whole backyard is nothing but concrete
so I need someone to come and power wash
it every few months because it starts to
not look good I do my own power washing
that's a different thing
you've got standards so yard looking
good Brandon if you were ever in the I
do Los Angeles area and you're looking
to just ending you enjoy what you do you
can stop by and landscape for us I love
I love landscaping and I do miss doing
it as a meditative aspect to like riding
on that you know rotating blade you know
what that is for me now what it is
taking leaves out of the pool with a big
net
it's kind of like raking a Zen garden I
actually play apple spa radio while I do
it
people think I got a frickin like you
don't do this temple up in my house I
play a solo I've good I got spa radio
playing I think there's marks up there
making my body hill lager and then they
get up there and
it's you cleaning out a pool in the way
that the pool area is with this like
it's kind of amplified with this like
concrete wall and yeah shoots it down
over over the the neighborhood and I
play it loud let blood and proud hit him
with it and I'm out there just
meditating just blast him with that
freaking a silent retreat all to myself
just with a big old thing pulling frogs
and uh the large bugs and just throwing
them over the side
I kid I make my kids do that teach him a
lesson Lando does that claire rebecca
lawrence asks a few guys ever ridden
horses before this is Jesse so this must
be a relative using a Jessie's using
Claire's could be my wife look at count
or you my wife may have a Facebook
account under Claire Rebecca Lawrence
why should why would she want to ask us
if we've ever ridden horses before maybe
she's dropping a hint big I had though
she was the horse but you know she likes
riding horses and she really enjoys it
well let me tell you you know I brought
this up you know I brought this up all
right so I was laying in bed next to my
wife well that's good Christie and we
don't we frequently do which is she's on
her phone on Instagram and Facebook yeah
that's what you do frequently and I'm
looking over her shoulder because I am
not active on Instagram or Facebook but
you could you want but I I mean I am
active over her shoulder actively
looking over oh sure I am I am socially
active with my wife in the bedroom on
her media mm-hmm and there was this
friend of hers that like she had she's
from North Carolina that you know an
acquaintance and she didn't even know
that well and I looked over so I was
like what's that in it you know how the
videos will just start playing on
Facebook and she's like scrawls girls
girl and it was a GoPro mounted on a
helmet of someone riding a horse no
sound you know sound up plate do you
like click on it or something
I mean I'm so ignorant that's how
Facebook works yeah and so I'm like she
kept strong as that was sad I don't know
so and so Michael you perform North
Carolina he said yeah she posted this
video of someone riding a horse and then
I I was like could i but have your phone
and then like I took the phone I went
back to that and I pressed play on it
and now I'm hearing sound horse sound
and for the next 14 minutes for 14
minute video of one woman talking horse
and one horse on one unedited ride and
it wasn't it was one of those things
where it's like they're jumping over the
bars and then we'll chase steeplechase
stuff and I don't know if it's go
steeplechase I think that's like oh I
was absolutely mesmerized by it is it
like VR horse riding it felt like I was
riding a horse you're laying in your bed
yeah yeah and did you take the phone
from your wife or did you make her watch
this with I I took it from her and then
what does she do I'll let her look over
my shoulder she wanted to she rolled
over and went to sleep if you're gonna
watch the horse video of course for like
14 minutes and I I realized for the
first time how amazing it could be to
ride a horse
well link it's a lot more amazing to
actually ride a horse well it I just
felt like I had some insight into it
have for the first time ever having that
perspective she was talking to the horse
and she was like okay you can do it not
don't get ahead of yourself cuz you see
the horse's head yeah see the horse's
head and I could see the jumps and
everything coming and like she was like
she was giving the horse physical
signals about what to do I inferred
because the things they should be in the
reins
yeah and the things that she was saying
was just verbally processing that's just
how she rides a horse she's like well
that was cool very anxious about gosh
you did a great job I mean she gives the
horse encouragement but she's like
alright okay stay with me stay with me
uh-huh and like she's saying things
rebuking though rebuking like she could
tell when the horse like lost interest
or was like going the wrong way or to do
that there's so much trust in that
relationship you're on the back
of a of a huge beast and you're you're
doing these little subtle physical
things that then send this beast that
you're on the back of over obstacles
soaring through the air but let me put
something over water over over bars let
me point something other if some I have
to do it yeah but riding a horse can be
arranged relatively easy I have to do it
this isn't like you know what I've got
to go to the Amazon
it isn't like something that requires a
lot of thought a lot of planning it's
like well we can ride a horse tomorrow
if you want to I mean literally we could
go to Griffith Park you could ride a
horse but yeah you know I've seen those
people and they're going in lines and
it's like you're looking at the horse in
front of you take a crap but hold on and
you're going you got to start somewhere
do you don't want to get on the horse
and have him jump over bars and stuff I
gotta do well I have oh well I'm Abed in
Costa Rica we rented rented ready the
horse we rode horses like Hertz rent a
horse and they were very like lakhs
about it's the state regulations and we
were just flying all over the place
going through the jungle I had that
thing galloping and I have no idea what
I'm doing why didn't you come back and
tell me I had to ride a horse well I
just I didn't know something you didn't
know about well are you it is the first
time you'd ridden a horse right no it
was like the eighth time I've ridden a
horse you've ridden a horse
eight times and this is how what it's
like and you've never told me I rode a
horse as a child one of my earliest
memories is being put on a horse like
how did you avoid you grew up in the
country how did you not get on a horse
my uncle Ross bought a horse for my
cousin Keith why didn't you get on the
horse well he got kicked off the horse
and he broke an arm and they tried to
put me on the horse once and I was
probably 7 or 8 years old you know I was
a real timid kid yeah it was scare me to
death because he was like I'll broke my
arm on this horse get up there but you
got you got to get it calm I was that's
why you you know what the interesting
thing and then I didn't do it
psychologically this is why your
favorite animal is a miniature horse
because you're scared of large horses
that's it we can't write a miniature
horse though that's inhumane you can
pull you in a cart
yeah but so we can work that out where's
the best place on earth to ride a horse
at and not at like a little not not like
it mule on at the Grand Canyon speed
that's what I want to know best place on
earth to ride a horse and that's where
I'm gonna okay let link know that I'm
gonna hashtag ear biscuit and I will I'm
like within minutes of a gallop I will
be I will be sobbing like a baby it is
really it is it is really great and
every time I do it I say why don't I do
this more so we got to come out horses
together I gotta tell link about this
Deirdre James asked if you had a pizza
that could talk would you still eat it
is this a question well but you know
before you answer that question we're
gonna take a short break to let you know
that we got new t-shirts so you know
what I'm gonna show you this one right
here cuz it's been sitting in my lap
getting warm so this this this lap baby
of mine is a t-shirt that's the official
ear biscuit finally we have an ear
biscuits t-shirt pocket and it's a
pocket teeka's pocket seize listen if
you're cool now you wear pocket tees if
you want to be cool do you want people
to know that you're a fan of your
biscuits now of course it's got the the
made by mythical seal in there
what could you put in that pocket you
put a dollar in there I could I could
probably put a like a thousand dollars
in there you could put a reminder to
ride a horse in there on a little note I
could put like a cardboard cutout of a
horse miniature horse peeking out of it
I got one to like look at this here's a
good place or should I be over here over
here okay this is the this is mythical
pocket tea if there's a it may be hard
to see in the dim lighting you can put a
thousand dollars in that pocket ooh
there's a pocket
again this is mythical YouTube channel
where if you are watching your biscuits
while you're listening to it you're
watching it most likely on that this is
mythical YouTube channel unless it's
been pirated somewhere and this is the
official symbol of the DISA's mythical
youtube channel and of course it has the
same made by mythical insignia but link
it doesn't stop there we also have
there's another show
oh sure we do a mythical morning good
mythical morning pocket tea we got
pocket teas for days this is we're
talking $3,000 now that you can hoist
around with yourself right where you
gonna keep your doesn't come with a
thousand dollar bill is it that was
another bill a thing I was saying once
like a thousand one's rolled up it would
be with you but no way it would look
about like that no way no way you could
fit that put that away
rhettandlink.com/store that's where you
get it yeah thanks for mentioning that
yeah that's really support internet team
okay Deirdre if you had a pizza that
could talk would you still eat it is
this is it of course yeah I don't have
to think about this one because just
because a piece of pizza is sentient or
sentient we're still the jury's still
out on what the correct way to say that
is but you say cinching it I say
sentient but I'm switching to sentient
how to pronounce sentient açaí gyro [ __ ]
how to pronounce it in any of those
sentient yeah let's play the how to
pronounce video this is how the world
works now sentient or sentient oh well
we have options well sentience wrong
sentient sentient or sentient so I was
sentient or sentient sentient since
sentient or sentient thirty thousand
views on this thing ten comments okay
what do you prefer we gotta make a
choice
first comment well which one is it
exactly well you got options man you got
choices yeah these are the only two
choices in my mind so I feel like there
should be one or the other but both
works I suppose well no no we can make
it we can make the definitive decision
right now do we have the authority to do
not I'm gonna have in my mind my vote
and you have in your mind you vote do
you understand my prompt yeah I'm gonna
have it but let me take your answer let
me tell you my rationale for why I'm
picking this I'm picking it because it
sounds more like what it means okay what
I just like sentient that's not an
option what you see there sentient or
sentient oh really you're saying the one
that I was saying earlier which is not
an option no ascension I thought I heard
that sentient is sentient or sentient
sentient you know sentient sentient yeah
didn't that sound like something that
note has knows itself sentient know
thyself what about sin chanting in pizza
sentient pizza so I was wrong I don't
care if with all the options that were
I'm honestly saying this I don't care if
a pizza has a soul has the ability to be
my friend a piece of pizza is still a
piece of pizza and its primary purpose
in the universe is to be eaten by me so
I don't care how smart it is I would
have a lovely conversation with it but I
would also eat it without hesitation as
long as they didn't have mouth parts or
a brain that would make it different
than pizza well no no no it has a mouth
dude yeah but it's like made of pizza
parts yeah kind of like it's like tongue
is like it is like a black Oliver's like
the VR burger that you were on good
mythical morning as long as it's pizza
to the core and no weird pizza brain
that's like something that you would
expect in a sentient being like I got a
eat around the tongue like I'm not gonna
eat the tongue yeah cuz it has a real
tough it has teeth they're like pieces
of you know just hard cheese or onions
onions better than that yeah onions the
lips are pepperoni
yeah in the eyeballs are eyeballs are
black olives that's what I should have
said but it's got a tongue that's like
salami
no problem there but while you're eating
it's like I'm not making it up I feel no
sympathy for it I think you're a
horrible horrible person really
I would only eat the talking pizza if
what it said was feel free to dine upon
me it's cool man I mean it would have to
I it would have to be like counselling
me through this traumatic event of me
eating the thing that's talking to me it
would have to be and you know what this
is what I this is what I made for I'm
not feeling any of this well I am
doesn't have a choice of what he's made
for now if there's a person who does if
it's a person who is somehow embodying a
piece of pizza either purposely or
accidentally is it a human voice or is
it a pizza voice I'm saying this is a
human voice coming out of a pizza I just
talked like the piece of pizza on Uncle
grandpa which is played by the guy that
sounds just like Jack Black and I think
is the guy from workaholics yeah who
he's hit him
we see at the Clippers game what's his
name Adam Adam I don't divine or Devine
I'm gonna have to figure I'm gonna have
to search that he's a sentient being
he's sentient yeah I would eat the piece
of pizza the pizza would have to be
constantly coaxing me into in the dining
on it
listen I'm in charge in this situation
between me and the piece of pizza gosh
next question I'd rather not I'd rather
not do this show with you anymore well
you're not a piece of pizza I know
you're not gonna eat me I'm just saying
I death eclis Christian or Kristen
Basford what is the best way to organize
your clothes hanging or folded should
shirts be color-coded or organized by
sleeve length or function how far apart
should hangers be placed lots of
questions in this well I've asked all of
these questions of myself and more when
it comes to them I'm sure when he oh
yeah when it comes to the organization
and placement of anything in my life my
wife and I are both in lockstep are you
in lockstep meaning that you see you
well it's not it's a little annoying but
listen I'm not asking you what what what
are our intimacy are you both in
lockstep I told you that you have the
same system or just you're both very
organized do you do you guys have the
same system to organize and close and
you discuss or do we have your own we
have a we have a walk-in closet that we
share off of our bedroom but it's
divided between your side and her side I
have my I have the end part and she has
the whole right side which is twice as
much as me and then she has the left
part for like shoes and then I have like
a half of a shelf for some of my shoes
and I was coming out of the walk-in
closet yesterday morning and she's in
the bathroom she came out at the same
time you're walking out I was walking
out and she was walking out of the
bathroom we met and she said did you
notice the closet and I was like no
actually and I turned around and looked
and it looked as pristine as it always
does and she was like I worked on the
closet yesterday I was like Oh ed
actually didn't your your side looks
great she was like no I worked on your
side too I removed all of the hangers
and we're being used and now they're in
this other place and she had organized
my closet because she loves me so much I
felt bad for not noticing you get to
she's more meticulous than I am that's
why I didn't notice but I think my
answer
I don't know Christy's answer I think
she does it differently it's not my
business but for mine which turns out is
her business because she can reorganize
it any way she wants and it's how she
shows she loves me and I accept it first
of all I like to hang stuff versus
folding things because there's lines on
stuff that are folded lies like clothing
lines yeah I know I still fold a lot of
stuff like my t-shirts are all folded
but I don't prefer it but I hang up my
all my shirts and but what do you but
what is your system how do you organize
the shirts because short sleeve button
ups then long sleeve button ups but then
within the long sleeve button ups it
goes from less dressy to more dressy
because on the far left side of my
closet it gets to dress shirts which are
also button-up long-sleeve shirts and
then to suits you know you accumulate
those suits that you wear once to like
award shows and then you never wear them
again I got but within those is a color
is there any color attention to color I
got all my plaids together and I got all
my solids together and then for the
short sleeve I have my plans together my
solids together but there's no like
gradation between you've got plaids
separate from colors but there's no like
darks to lights there's no spectrums no
that it's just either colors or plaids
because they have so many plaids and I
have to make decisions like what am I
wearing on good mythical morning I don't
want to wear too many plaids in a row or
too many solids you might see you may be
surprised to know this that I mean
what's yours I'm assuming that you just
think my is just a free-for-all but and
it can be at times but first of all
Jesse and I have invested in all wooden
hangers so they're like bigger and nicer
and it keeps everything separated and
we've gotten rid of the what were the
wire hangers and sometimes the wire
hangers get in there when you bring
something back from the dry cleaner and
then you've got that's what Christie
cleaned out of myself
and as much as as much as I'm not really
the anal about this stuff it does bother
me and I do like to have them I do like
to have mother I've experimented with
Judy with two different ways I at one
point experimented with a fully
color-coordinated closet I mean meaning
you did it once and then it just evolved
over time meaning that I did it in the
norm didn't realize that you make
choices about your you're more often the
driving factor in making a choice about
clothing is occasion and whether right
which means that the function of the
clothing be it yeah more dressy less
dressy or long-sleeve short-sleeve
that's the driving factor in the choice
matrix that you have in front of you so
you you you evolved into my system yeah
but I'm very bad about maintenance
keeping it intact because tough I get
home and I'm like and then and then I've
got like I don't I don't like to put
things in the dirty clothes oh yeah
I got a chair and I just Drake Drake
Drake Drake well what I do is at the end
of the day I smell the pits because
that's really the only I don't get
stains I'm not a child I don't get
stains on my shirt so I I smell my my
armpits
it goes in the bin not while it's on I
take it off of me oh and you see they're
not smelly because yes that's good point
and then I'm like is this acceptable and
then there's a there's a there's a level
of Bo that you can smell in the pits
that you know will dissipate within 24
hours yeah or the next time you wear it
and then there's a level of stink that
you know is so deep set that this is
this is it's like an animal irredeemable
animal mating scent yeah yes and this is
the kind of thing that you have two
choices you can get a dry clean or you
can sit it into a spot in your closet
for like two or three months and let it
just evolve the sin away yeah it'll
whatever's living there will die yeah so
I don't stick with this very often but I
do we do have a relatively we're gonna
end the same percentage breakdown
between my my side we have a walk-in
closet and she takes up 75% of it I've
recently had a negotiation to get back a
section of the closet oh you're trying
to reclaim I said like land and the
once I just exactly I said you gotta
build a shirt canal I would really like
to get this section back because I hope
you I hope you really built that up well
no but you know what it was it was like
to go out to dinner is this what you
just talked about with the dress clothes
so with being on Fallon two times this
year and then like we mentioned we were
on some awards show and some awards
shows we get yeah we never dress up so
we had these very few occasions that we
dress up and we always get something new
for those occasions and then I just have
this outfit that's big and bulky and
there's like bag and leave it all
together and it's like my dress section
got bigger than it needed to be and now
I'm just spilling man I'm spilling
everywhere you know what you should do
is I'm negotiating for that spot I don't
have it yet though you should you should
pay your gardener in suits get a tall
garden it's not my size Arthur James
Fred frugal
if you guys weren't doing ggm I don't
know what that is we were not doing it
good good morning and you mean G and
then that's fine I'm not gonna make fun
of it what would your dream jobs be and
this is tough now we've answered this
before I've been thinking about this
because we've answered this before that
I would be a paleontologist I would be a
hairstylist again I'd be a professor
that was a paleontology professor and
then we went to dig up by dinosaur bones
I might be a traveling hairstylist I
don't want to be confined to one place I
might be on like digs but can I be the
hair cutter on the digs yeah yeah no
problem
but recently I've been thinking about
this more and I think I actually have a
come up with a job that doesn't exist
and I would like and that is a fast food
item taster somebody who lives at home
yeah it has experimental items that are
going to be introduced at fast-food
restaurants like whatever the next
magrib is or whatever the next weird
Carl's jr. thing where they put like
four different kinds of meat together on
a sandwich
Taco Bell's got a lot of desperation
yeah and because I'm the kind of guy
that responds to this sort of
advertising in these newfangled
rearrangements of food that already
exists you want them to post made I want
them to give it to me so I can give this
mate or post mate you can do whatever
you want to toast mate it I will take it
and I will eat it and I will give notes
on it to let the fast-food people know
if it's a good idea or not because I've
got a good palate for that kind of thing
and like that except a lot of things
what's that wine a wine tastes are
called sommelier yeah you're like a
fast-food Amal yeh yeah I you know an
experimental food Amole eh yeah so that
would be I think I would just work on a
factory line oh really
like pull the lever pull the lever
mindlessly pull the lever simple it's
just it leaves
creaks lots of brain space for all those
kinds of thoughts other things okay or
no things all right noted that
meditative state you were taught earlier
and you might refer to it as a rut pull
lever I could see you do as a man I can
see you doing that Darleen Eagle ask us
now that it is possible is it ethical
for me to raise my kids almost
exclusively on all of the 80s and 90s
entertainment I enjoyed as a kid is it
ethical for her to only show her kid
things that she enjoyed as a kid I don't
know I don't know this is a serious
question I'm going to but it is a it is
possible because there's so much retro
stuff happening what fuller house well
that's what that wouldn't technically be
I don't think I would apply here because
that's not it's it's from the 90s but
it's not it's of the nineties but it is
not that's from the ninety it will be
watching actual full house this is a
good question because first of all I
don't abide by this I'm not gonna judge
your ethics either way but m'as remind
me I do show my kids things that I
enjoyed as a kid you know let's watch
Back to the Future together let's watch
ET let's watch Goonies let's watch these
80s movies that were very formative well
I did that too but for me it was I want
you to watch all the movies that I
should have watched as a kid because you
didn't watch any of those movie which is
every single one you just mentioned I
for the first time along with Mike in
the past five years but uh I was just
saving it it's like a it's it's like a
form of entertainment virginity and some
of that stuff holds up you know I mean
some of the movies hold up and some of
them don't some of them you're like man
it was bad back then and some of them
you're like this is so good and kids are
a great judge you know barometer for
that because I thought Ghostbusters one
hello pretty well Ghostbusters 2 didn't
like like The Gargoyle thing said I mean
there was a claymation moment like that
didn't hold up other than the comedy
certainly held up and it made up for any
of the special effects which then some
of many of those still held up but this
Slimer but this raises another question
that is related to this in somewhat
seriously this is your question somewhat
serious go it go for it just because the
question is about kids and what they
watch and that kind of thing because
sometimes you'll watch like something
from the 80s and you're like oh it's PG
this is totally fine and then you
realize that PG in 1985 was a totally
different thing
oh yeah like Beetlejuice would drop an
f-bomb right and so that reminds me of
something that we we see this repeatedly
on our videos right so we live in the
comment culture where we know what you
think about what we do and that's the
that's part of what the business that
were in
and on a somewhat frequent basis we make
a video that has what a certain
percentage of our audience thinks is
questionable content right one of the
most recent is when we put on women's
bras and put some double D gel based
boobies in the bra and we proceeded to
bounce around in slow motion to see to
ask a legitimate question which was
what's the best sports bra I mean you
need to know these kinds of things
well yeah you need to know those type of
things but it also seems like it would
be pretty hilarious for us to then our
application is we're gonna be the ones
to test it we're not gonna get women in
here to do it right of course we could
have done that but whenever we do
something like you know women whenever
we do something like that okay a couple
of grown men wearing bras jumping around
boobs going all over the place even
though they are gel boobs
real boobs falling outs platen there's a
certain person with a certain
sensibility or sensitivity who's like I
don't find this content appropriate
right and specifically it's usually I
don't feel comfortable letting my
children watch the show with me anymore
because you guys do things like this now
you're you're you're you're basically
quoting a comment that we read
oh I'm quoting a this is a
representative comment that's on that
particular video but it's on a certain
percentage of our videos where we cross
what some people proceed to be a line
that we shouldn't cross yeah and there's
different those lines are different for
different things it's not just when we
do things that women should do would
that they think women should do well I
mean it could be anything there's
there's a number of different things I
don't want to get into the nature of
what triggers certain people but I do
want to talk about it because I think
it's it this isn't it I I'm genuinely
interested in this I mean the first
thing I'll say is that I don't place any
blame on somebody who says I think you
guys crossed a line and this isn't what
I want my kids to watch it's your you
you make the decisions for your children
that you feel are best and that's your
business and I have absolutely no
judgment on that I have nothing to say
about it so the second thing I will say
that because about that one
we certainly learnt being parents
ourselves you learn very early when
you're talking to other parents that you
got to be very careful about passing
judgment on decisions they make his
parents right I mean I do that a long
time ago well because you have kids
doesn't mean you start talking about
what other people should know there's
people who don't have kids who judge
people raise their right but when you
have them you're like oh crap okay all
right I'm not gonna judge anybody no but
no I think these comments are coming
from people with kids and they're like
I'm not comfortable with my kids
watching your show because you wore a
sports bra with fake boobs in it and you
jumped around people just people just
say you crossed a line or whatever now
one thing I will say also is that this
is not new we've been getting these
comments for 11 years ever since we've
been doing YouTube people like to think
that things have changed that things
have gotten worse but we've gotten these
comments all along the way but the thing
the second thing I'll say is that our
show and in every
thing that we do none of it is targeted
at kids none of it is intended
especially for children right our
content is content that we with our
videos or videos that we think are funny
so one question is do you guys think
this stuff is funny well we wouldn't do
it if I I think when I see link in a bra
a sports bra I find that funny yes when
we put fake boobs in there and he starts
jumping around on trampoline yes I find
that funny we wouldn't do it if we
didn't think it was funny yeah when you
were when you did the the Pamela
Anderson Baywatch run I thought that was
a lyric I found that very helpful yeah
I've been watching myself multiple times
over the past couple weeks yeah so our
contents not in not intended for kids
however everything that we for the most
part everything that we do especially
anything that you're going to see on
good mythical morning we make it the
standard that we kind of apply to it is
that I would let anyone that I know
watch the things that we do on good
mythical morning now it's not for kids
but I personally would let I'm not gonna
do anything on the show that I don't
think a kid could watch my standard
might be different than yours and and
well I go one step further I mean I
think we've said this before but my own
kids like I don't want to I was about to
say I don't want to go home show my kids
in episode and be embarrassed but I'm
being embarrassed cuz it's so ridiculous
I mean they're not really embarrassed
but I'm not gonna like say all right
even Lando and you know you're eight
years old you but you can't you can't
watch this episode but he's not eight
years old how old is he
seven ninety seven years old yeah seven
yeah cuz my son is eight years old yeah
that's right yeah he was six yeah that's
what confused me the YouTube I thought
he wasn't even um you don't go from six
to eight though that doesn't happen
anymore I thought he was an even number
I got three man I know it's tough to
keep up 14 and 12 I got that on the lock
and then seven and then it'll change
well locks you son's name but that's not
what a man yeah anyway what I'm saying
is I'm comfortable with my kids even at
age seven watching everything we do but
I don't make it for my seven-year-old to
watch it's kind of what you're saying
yeah and and people have different
standards in it
like I said we live in a comment culture
we're gonna continue to get those
comments you can continue to make those
comments but I think it's important to
understand those two things that a it's
not for kids
B we make cut we make stuff that we
think is funny and I'm gonna add a C
just to clarify and we do things that we
think is appropriate for everyone for
all ages and we wrought that's what
we're gonna do when it comes to good
mythical morning and you know you can
you can draw a line in a different place
that's where we draw the line we're not
trying to push the limits we're doing we
think is funny inappropriate what he's
saying is we're sorry and we won't do it
again yeah I think that's what he's
saying
another question breezy breezy Breanna
Steen Stein breezy Stein breezy Stein
you know if you get yourself a big Stein
that's like a glass she says why are
Egyptian artifacts and tombs cursed you
never hear about Greek temples or tombs
being cursed do Aztec temples have
curses not equipped to answer this one
I'm not sure why I asked it I don't know
that I've never heard about a Greek
temple or tomb being cursed well here's
what I'll say this is my honest answer I
could have heard about it and it just
didn't stick with me I don't think any
anything is cursed I don't think curses
are real and I don't think they're I
don't think they're physically possible
I don't believe in those kinds of
metaphysical things and therefore I
don't believe the Egyptian artifacts are
tombs have curses that are any different
than Greek or Aztec temples but then if
you were in like an Egyptian tomb and it
was dark you remember that time we were
that filmfest I'd still be scared and we
went down in those stairs and because
you were like there's some stairs in the
back of this old theater and it is dark
I mean like pitch dark let's go down
there I don't believe in ghosts but I'm
still no you got scared but I still get
scared deep down yeah so maybe that
maybe that's revealing something maybe
knowing something that your mind doesn't
know I think it's I think it's a
survival adaptation I think that if
there's something enters your mind as a
possibility that could harm you and if
that enters your mind because of
cultural customs or something you see in
a movie then if you find yourself in a
situation where it's actually to your
advantage to picture those things in
your mind
want to avoid them where is it actually
maybe some impulse that results from
like wanting to make sure that like a
lions not about to jump outside a
bushing and eat you you're sounding very
Greek right now yeah
maybe that's it maybe the maybe the
Greek culture didn't allow for the for
the curses Josh gazzarri do you wipe
sitting down or standing up we answered
this question on we explored this in
depth on good mythical more mythical
more and we asked the because we played
what we played a guessing game with the
with the crew but and let me just answer
it again with I wipe sitting down dude
well reach-around like I said the white
how I'm sitting down and then I do one
last one standing up just to make sure
just on your way out but I'm gonna do
this I haven't asked permission but I'm
gonna do this because I feel like I need
to don't wipe right now I feel like I
need to set the record straight for Alex
because we What did he say Alex said
that he wiped from the front which ever
since he said that everybody's thought
he's crazy and if you've tried to wipe
from the front you recognize that would
be a crazy thing to do for anybody man
or woman Alex doesn't actually wipe from
the front but he said that he wiped from
the front because he misunderstood the
game when the game went when it was told
to him what he the answers that he would
be writing down on that thing to when he
had to play the game he thought that he
was supposed to be making up an answer
to try to get us to believe something
and then once the game started happening
he realized that he was supposed to have
answered the question honestly because
it wasn't explained to him thoroughly he
was supposed to lie and then stick to it
and so there's part of that like are you
lying and then it'll be revealed a I was
lied at the end and so then in the mint
in the midst of the game he felt the
pressure and he went ahead and said I
wiped from the front and tried to defend
it and now everybody thinks that he's
crazy he's a crazy person and he didn't
feel well he might be but not fair and
he didn't feel right about stopping and
saying guys I didn't understand the game
that's why you love Alex
I don't really wife in the front so
thank you Alex for going along the game
but I just feel like we should set the
record straight that Alex wipes like a
normal person he is not wiping from the
front he never did never will
well I'll tell you I mean moment of
honesty here I'm you know what I'm not
ashamed of this I have taken up recently
the practice of peen sitting down and
I'm not gonna but I'm not gonna
apologize to you or anyone but I am
gonna try to explain myself yeah
well please do it mostly at work because
what's happening is hold on you're
sitting down on these and and I'm
sitting down on these yeah I'm p.m. yeah
and here's why but what I've noticed is
that I don't go to the bathroom to pee
until I really really have to go
mm-hmm that's healthy because we're
we're so busy you know we move from one
thing to the next and I mean I'm not
complaining I'm just saying that we move
from things so quickly there's no it's
not
well you almost have to schedule time to
pee because of how we move around to
stuff yeah I've noticed that lately
people for I think we're like you guys
what do you guys do well I'm not gonna
try to defend our schedule but I will
say that not even the peeing is a burden
lately it is a burden right I got to get
into this thing and we got to have this
conversation about this thing we gotta
move we gotta have this meeting but I
have to pee I'm gonna be two minutes
late for this meaning every second
counts so you hold it and hold it so I'm
like holding it through meetings or
chutes or whatever I have to pee like a
Russian racehorse right now and I don't
know what that means if that's offensive
to people
well I think he goes back to it if I
just offended a Russian racehorse I'm
sorry it's not Russian as in like the
over country Russia is Russian like are
you Shi in ' Russian oh it's like
they're rushing to the restroom I have
no idea I look that up is it Russian
racehorse or Russian racehorse let me
make my point I think it's Russian like
Russia the country so when I get to the
bathroom all right I'll look it up yeah
I got an O now P like a Russian
racehorse Russian racehorse origin
because it did come up as Russian in the
seventies trainers started giving a drug
called lasix to their horses the drug
causes the animals to pee urgently and
copiously before a race often in front
of the crowd
P like a rush Russian racehorse the
expression probably originated in rural
America where people know about horses
oh they know about horses but we're
always coming back to horses but what
has it what Russian had it was a Russian
about it the Russian and in Russia did
you give him LASIK surgery is that what
you said no it was a drug that like they
would get them to evacuate before to
lighten the load before a race often in
front of the crowd well that was
interesting and I don't know why they're
Russian the Russians tend to I mean they
are the ones that are most often caught
in the doping scandals I will say that
so I guess it applies to the horses as
well nothing against the Russian the
people enjoying the show I'm just saying
you got a reputation for doing the
doping when it comes to the Olympics and
stuff you know no harm no foul
but you know we don't allow that yeah I
think it's something in there I mean
what's your point though so when I get
to the restroom I got I've got quite a
payload and I would stand and pee and
forever to the point where I would get
tired gosh and standing and I would have
and yeah but I would have to I would try
to rush it like I try to like rush it
I'm try to speed up the the rate at
which the eggs it occurred which you can
do you know that's it that's not that's
not because literally I was like I know
people are waiting on me for the next
thing that's not the way to and that's
not good though right and I was like
first of all I'm not gonna do that
anymore but I then it's just taking so
long and I feel like I'm standing there
forever I I just need a rest so I was
like next time I'm sitting down and I'm
gonna take it as a little respite and
I'm and I'm actually going to get done
quicker than trying to force it and then
think I'm done and then I'm not you
remember that scene and um a league of
their own where Tom Hanks's penis stop
you know Davis can hear it he stops and
he starts again and he stops and he
starts again
yeah I laughed so hard the first time I
saw that scene in that movie it may have
been the hardest I've ever laughed at a
movie that's it was so funny to me and I
can relate to it so just you know just
going with it it's kind of like you
cleaning out the leaves from your pool
playing them the the spa music like that
is now what I feel like when I pee I
just relax and I'm like this is gonna
take the amount of time it's gonna take
in the world is gonna stop it's all
gonna melt away and then I'm gonna flush
it and it's a moment of centering for me
no I can't I can't you can't do that
stand I can't hold that against you if
that's what you see it is but I see it
as a as a privilege you know it's to me
it's like throwing a rock at a pole or
something like that it's I don't need to
I know no need to turn everything into a
carnival game but why not if I have my
life's fun enough I've got an object or
in this case a stream and then there's a
ring that I can aim at you know I think
of it this way if I understand I go to
the State Fair I get after hours and I
go past the game you don't pee on it no
no I mean if I go past that game where
you try to throw the ball into the
bucket and make it go up and then the
board and then go into the bucket and I
don't have to pay a dollar a ball
you're gonna pee on that I'm gonna go
and I'm gonna do it every trip to the
bathroom for me is like a free State
Fair carnival game where I always win
because because I am gonna feel good
that I have there's a reward there's an
intrinsic reward of relief and I can aim
at different things and unless I don't
want to get graphic here but if
somebody's left like a little something
on the inside of the ball I aim at that
and clean it right up like a freaking
power power washer you should come to my
concrete backyard you have absolutely no
opportunity to do that by sitting down
because it's all in the dark by sitting
down it's like going to the State Fair
and just sitting in the bucket that
they're trying to throw the ball in
that's not playing the game that's the
guy just relaxing you're like
karni taking it taking a break yeah in
an endless night there's nothing there's
nothing wrong with that but I see life
as a game and you see it as an
opportunity for respite no my life is a
game but you sometimes you gotta you
gotta work the bench well that's what
taking a crap is about link for me it's
spending a little extra time on there
not too long until you find em roids
I need more breaks that's only I only
have one of those a day man so that's it
I I don't sit down all the time I just
sit down when I've got a really full
bladder okay Isaac James asks what do
you think of the newfound shrimp species
Pink Floyd can you look this up link
because I know nothing about I heard
about this it is a new shrimp species
that was discovered that was named after
pink floyd because of this very large
pink claw so it's just pink floyd and
then IA at the end of it
shrimp shrimp pink floyd a shrimp Pink
Floyd yeah shrimp recipes know and click
on that picture click on one of those
pictures there this thing it's amazing
because a video it has the ability with
that pink claw Wow to vibrate that pink
claw it's such a frequency that it
creates a sound that is so loud that it
creates this bubble no fish I have heard
about this is their technical
information about it in the article
because I want I want to know if I'm
right about this it snaps right what
does it say technically so I don't know
watch the video read the article because
it says it I don't like to just read
it's like three paragraphs at most it's
like one paragraph the shrimp found on
Panama's Pacific coast has been dubbed
San epheus Pink Floyd eeeh Pink Floyd II
in the peer-reviewed journal ZOA taxa
Oxford University Museum of Natural
History researchers Sammy is one of
three researchers credited with
discovering the creature he says the
description of the shrimp was the
perfect opportunity to finally give a
nod to my favorite band but what does
the shrimp do according to Oxford pistol
or snapping shrimps close their enlarged
claws and a
rapid speed to create an imploding
bubble the result is a sound so loud it
can kill or stun a fish what in the
world how does this happen he's it's
like his claw is emitting this is
yelling it's like breaking the sound
barrier or something well these are all
my words which means they're all
inaccurate so I can just read this again
rapid speed to create an imploding
bubble the result is it sounds so loud
it can killer stunts so how can you move
your your claw so fast underwater that
it creates a implode I don't understand
I don't understand the science but I
will answer the question what do you
think of it I think it's awesome
I think it's honestly I'm not a huge fan
of the when they named something after a
ban or something like that the reason
they do it and I understand the reason
they do it the reason scientists do this
is because today scientists in order to
get normal people to care about the work
that they're doing they have to get cute
because a lot of people don't care about
science yeah so you got to have guys
like Bill Nye got to put some rock music
in it or Neil deGrasse Tyson yeah we've
got to be cool and have to and I'll and
I love both of those guys and think
they're doing great work but the fact
that they have to be cool and explain
everything in like a a dumb down way to
get anybody to care about it I think is
kind of sad you got to call the shrimp
pink floyd-- just so people who care
about it isn't it awesome enough that
this shrimp has the ability to vibrate
it's freaking claw at a frequency that
creates a imploding bubble that can kill
a fish that you don't need Pink Floyd to
make that awesome Pink Floyd is there
they're a group and here's them be
awesome with their music but let the
shrimp be awesome by himself and give
him the right in the privilege of having
a name all to himself why don't have to
name him after a band are we really that
desperate for clicks yes we are yes we
are now let me read a little bit more
because even the details once we dig a
layer deeper it gets even more
fascinating I think I
I can't remember where I heard about
this but I've heard about it
the shrimp can close its claw at amazing
speeds the two clap the two claw halves
hit each other on claw closure up to
30,000 rpms the tip of the moving part
of the claw moves it 20 meters per
second the water that is located between
the claw halves is squeezed out and
forms a water jet with a speed of 30
meters per second or 100 km/h the speed
of the water jet is so high that we get
a drop of the pressure to pressure to
below the vapor pressure of water
resulting in cavitation cavitation
occurs when the water velocity is very
high in which case the pressure drops
considerably because of the Bernoulli
principle the pressure drops even below
the vapor pressure of water and the
water will vaporize or boils so to say
what yeah he's boiling things don't war
in the ocean the water is moving so fast
it basically boils so why don't we add a
named after pink floyd now i will say
we're talking about it because he named
it after pink floyd we're being amazed
by science because some scientists
decided to name a big thing for it and
what can we say I mean talk about the
clickbait culture I mean what do we do
for a living baton click baby you know
but I'm not saying bait and switch but
it's you can't bait and switch 8 and
click and satisfy when you go that's our
thing bait for the click and then
deliver and then late and click and
deliver it's like it's like an OBGYN mmm
I don't want to know how that makes
sense we can explore it let's let's end
with one here from Darwin Hannon who
says holy cow I didn't even realize your
biscuits was back wow that's not a
question that's a comment but I do think
it's disturbing because I think you know
this is telling Darwin nothing against
you you didn't know you don't watch
every video that's cool it's not your
fault most people don't but I think what
this represents is a situation a
situation that if you were currently
listening or watching this podcast you
can have the opportunity to help with
and
that is not everybody knows about this
you know we put it over here on the
disses mythical channel and of course we
put it wherever podcasts are available
but it between season two of your
biscuits the season three of your
biscuits definitely oh break it's like
the gap between the claw pieces was
really wide and now we're just trying to
bring it down trying to move it at 20
meters per second to trying to get some
negative pressure to weakens you back
into this podcast room yes do it
have your people back but what you can
do is you can tell people listen you
know and maybe they're maybe you've got
friends who are like I don't watch those
idiots to dress up in women's clothes
and shake their boobs all around I'm not
into that what do you think who do you
think I am my kids can't watch that we
get it but there's more but we do more
to us than that every week we sit down
at this table and we have what we think
you don't have to tell them is a
conversation what they just had it we
think it is a conversation do you think
it's a conversation well let them
describe it any way they want think it's
a conversation worth listening to
well then tell them tell other people
about it tell the Darwin in your life it
means the world to us and other ways
that you can help continue to support
your biscuits and make sure that your
biscuit stays here for a good while is
leaving reviews on iTunes
commenting liking here on YouTube what
are things can they do there's other
things that you can do in other places
wherever you enjoy podcasts sit while
peeing make me a reservation to ride a
horse in an exotic location okay or
record those shrimp which is difficult
to do because of acoustics underwater
yeah it's difficult and I think you just
asked a lot of the people I was asking
for likes and comments and sharing and
telling reposting this oh is that this
isn't the time for my wish list tweet
about it hashtag your biscuits you know
that kind of yeah hash tag your biscuit
the easy stuff on social media let us
know what you think yes thank you for
being your mythical best will speak at
you next week is every Monday morning
[Music]